now let's go from hannity to another fox
news propagandist tucker carlson how is
he reacting to the russian invasion of
ukraine well he's doing it by siding
with vladimir putin
as vladimir putin quite literally
was invading ukraine yesterday
tucker carlson came out and said hey
ukraine isn't even a democracy it's not
even a democracy implicitly justifying
the russian invasion here is tucker
last night
ukraine is not even a democracy despite
what joe biden endlessly claims ukraine
is a corrupt eastern european autocracy
that has spent millions of dollars
lobbying politicians in washington and
by the way made joe biden's family writ
okay
so
tucker isn't wrong
in the sense that ukraine
is
a corrupt autocracy
but russia is even more of a corrupt
autocracy so justifying the more corrupt
autocracy
invading
the less corrupt autocracy in this way
really doesn't make any sense and you
know let's let's dig into this a little
bit more
whether we call something a democracy
is very binary
the point is there are major issues in
ukraine major issues with the rule of
law major issues with the administration
of justice in ukraine women's rights are
kind of a disaster in ukraine freedom of
expression hate crimes are out of
control in ukraine you're the real
serious issues in ukraine
but number one those issues are worse
than russia but that's kind of what
about ism so let's not even focus on
that
it's it's kind of weird
for tucker to justify
russia's invasion of ukraine over things
that russia has a worse record on but in
a sense it's what about ism the real
issue is tucker implicitly invalidating
ukraine's sovereignty and saying putin
can decide what happens in ukraine if
putin decides that ukraine
is corrupt
putin can invade that's really the issue
the implied point is that ukraine isn't
even a democracy
so therefore it's okay for putin to
invade everything he says about ukraine
applies to russia 10 times over is
russia a democracy is putin not corrupt
is there freedom of the press in russia
come on come on and the u.s propaganda
machine
sails
full speed ahead and um it it to some
degree i feel like we don't even have
like a real defense against this type of
propaganda um
it it
it has pervaded and so many people are
literally rooting for putin and russia
here and against joe biden which is
which is a very strange way of showing
how america first you are as they claim
to be um also funny
is that the right wingers
accusing ukraine of not being a
democracy
are the people who have been accepting
trump's efforts to undermine american
democracy i mean the number of
hypocrisies
and contradictions is stunning the very
same people who despite joe biden
winning in 2020
said well
i don't know that he really won and it
would have been fine for pence to
overturn it it would have been fine for
the rioters to prevent the certification
uh to try to give trump another
opportunity it would have been fine for
states to send alternate electors as
arizona and some other states were
thinking of doing as part of the
so-called green bay sweep they have
undermined american democracy at every
opportunity and now are justifying
putin's invasion of ukraine by saying
well ukraine's not really a democracy
come on now think back to the second
iraq war in 2003.
in 2003 when people like me were saying
this war doesn't make any sense
we shouldn't be doing this this is a
terrible idea ukra
iraq didn't even have weapons of mass
destruction the entire intelligence case
made for going into iraq is bogus
these right-wingers were saying you're
rooting against america you're rooting
against our troops you're defending
saddam and they were wrong of course
saddam was a bad guy but things were
relatively stable geopolitically with
his presence in iraq but he didn't have
anything to do with 911 and he didn't
have weapons of mass destruction we
weren't rooting against the u.s we were
saying let's not even get involved in
this those people who said you're
rooting against the us they are
literally defending and supporting putin
now
and we saw clips from from tucker there
are clips from hannity here's one other
bizarre clip from last night's tucker
carlson show where he says
he sent
a letter
to both the russian and ukrainian
presidents as well as to congressman
david cicilline and that sicilini is
repulsive but hopefully he'll agree to
be interviewed like it's beyond parody
so today we sent another letter to
vladimir putin asking for an interview
right we get it we also sent a message
to the president of ukraine we would
like that interview too okay now neither
one of these men runs a democracy by
traditional american standards both of
them are tyrants true but they're in the
news and we would love to talk to them
an interview is hardly an endorsement
in that same spirit we've also reached
out to congressman cicilline's office
inviting him on this show david
cicilline is a former mafia lawyer who
represents one of our most corrupt
states he is a repulsive man
is it immoral to talk to him no it's not
immoral it would be interesting and so
we hope congressman cicilline accepts
our invitation
i mean
it's beyond parody the congressman is a
repulsive man and we hope that he
accepts our invitation to be interviewed
we've dealt with booking what we might
call hostile or adversarial guests
one of the things we never do
is to say we find you repulsive in
asking for the interview it's i it's
just i know tucker has a whole team of
people over there
i would suggest
not
violently
with rhetoric right now physically uh
attacking the character of the people
that you're trying to interview we'll
have these clips on our instagram if
you're just listening today
find us on instagram at david pakman
show
one of our long time sponsors is vincero
collective i love vincero's watches
you've heard me talk about them before
they now offer sunglasses and a bunch of
other premium accessories for men and
women vincero is committed to creating
exceptionally crafted watches and
accessories and doing so ethically fair
pricing carbon neutrality vincero puts
their principles first which is
important to me i just picked up the
rogue from vincero in gunmetal and red i
love the intricate design on the watch
face and the multiple sub-dials the
durable black silicone strap looks great
with just about anything i'm wearing in
all of vincero's products whether it's
the watches the glasses men's or women's
you can just see and feel the quality so
if you want to elevate your look or you
want to find the perfect valentine's day
gift for that special someone pick
something up at vincero vincero
collective is giving my audience 15 off
all products and free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below